what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
june the 30th the month is [__] over
the joint is brought to you by magnesium
breakthrough
listen if you're a man you got to do you
got to go to the doctor even if you
don't want to
if you're ignoring how you feel you need
to listen to this
fatigue anxiety headaches all that might
come back to one thing
you're not getting enough magnesium
magnesium breakthrough is the cure
magnesium is an amazing [__] mineral
not only does it help you sleep it also
reduces stress
and maintains a regular heartbeat and
boosts immunity
i've been on this since i signed with
magnesium breakthrough and i got to tell
you something i take one
they have a special menu for you to take
and it's tremendous you take day week
week one you take one cap in the am
one in the afternoon and one
one hour before you go to bed and then
it increases over time
then you go to three caps an hour before
you go to bed
and this will help you with maintenance
and sleep optimization you understand me
eighty percent of the population is
magnesium
deficient i'm amazed at how much better
i've been sleeping
and how rested i feel in the morning
since i've been taking the magnesium
breakthrough now
magnesium breakthrough is the only
organic supplement that includes seven
unique forms
of magnesium it works fast i feel in
about 30 minutes
just pop two the three capsules before
you go to bed
and your tip top magoo so for the joint
family
go to magbreakthrough.com
show you again magbreakthrough.com
showy and use code joey10
during checkout to save 10
that's mag breakthrough mag
breakthrough dot-com slash showy
and use code joey 10 for 10 percent off
when you see the sandman tell them uncle
joey sent you this [__] is [__]
tremendous i love it
i use it every night the joint is also
brought to you by
relief band did you know a third of
americans suffer from [__] nausea
i did when i was taking those [__]
pain pills
that's why i'm excited about [__]
relief band
relief band was sent to me and i didn't
know who the [__] sent it i thought
the surgeon sent it to me and i found
out it was the company and next thing
you know
they were sponsoring me and i was using
it the product is 100
drug free it doesn't make you drowsy and
has zero side effects
this used to only be available for
hospital patients but now
it's available for everybody and this is
how it works
relief band stimulates a nerve in the
wrist that travels to the part of your
brain that controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach
telling you that you're sick that's
[__] science
relief ban is only over-the-counter
wearable band that has been used in
hospitals
and oncology clinics to help with nausea
and vomiting listen
when i was recovering from this [__]
knee surgery
those pills were [__] killing me i
put the watch on and between me and you
i only got [__] sick
two times once in the car and once i was
down here moving around a little bit too
quick
ensure nausea is never the reason to
miss out on life's important [__]
moments
right now relief band has an exclusive
offer
for uncle joey joint listeners listen i
know you got family
your parents are old your uncles go to
reliefband.com
that's reliefband.com use promo code
joey and you'll receive
20 off plus free shipping and a no
question 30 day money back guarantee
relief ban r e l i e f
b a n dot and use promo code joey for 20
here it is right here it's nice simple
you just go like this you control how
much you want you could turn it down
this is the relief band that's it so go
to reliefband.com
use promo code joey and get 20
off and get some relief from nausea
let's get this party started
it's [__] on wednesday
let's talk about a little [__]
gambling today all right
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
june 30th it's a beautiful [__] day
welcome to uncle joey's joint
today i want to talk to you about
[__] gambling man let me tell you a
little story about what happened to me
in 1991 when i got
divorced i had a little bit of money in
the bank
i had a condo i had a nice car i had a
truck
i didn't have much money but i had some
money put away when i got separated
and divorced the [__] divorce
destroyed me it destroyed me guys i used
every [__] card i had
i think i owed one attorney a hundred
thousand dollars
just the one main guy and i had to pay
him
because he was referred to me by a
friend
you know at the end i didn't get what i
wanted from the attorney but
i had to go through like three different
attorneys before i got the main attorney
i was in debt probably 140 000 to
attorneys
and i was probably in debt maybe a
hundred thousand dollars on credit cards
and some of it was cocaine i know a lot
of years ago yeah you were doing coke
but it wasn't
the thing that killed me was just uh the
attorney fees i don't know if you've
ever hired an attorney
for anything it's 5 000 up front and 300
every time you call
you know and this is before emails and
[__] i don't know what they charge you
for a [__] email
i had to pay that [__] dude back i
had to pay him back
i had to figure out a way so like a man
i went
over to his [__] office and i told
him it's gonna take time
you know it was 1990 [__] two uh
i'm doing comedy i'm selling [__]
neon
and i'm trying the best i [__] can't
you know
and on top of that i had to live i had
to live myself you know i was making
no money is a comic maybe 200 a month as
a comic and that was the little hosting
gig i had
and i was in all this debt when i used
to work at the puddle car wash when i
was married these guys would come in
a bunch of them like three or four guys
would come in once a week with nice cars
they were all new yorkers and they would
talk to me
and i would ask them what they did and
they would always high-hand me like ah
we work for this guy you know whatever
this happened for about a year
you know i asked them if i could get in
with them i didn't know what they did
but i knew they all drove nice [__]
cars a lot nicer than the car i had
and they had families and they had money
so
i never really thought about it i ended
up quitting the car wash and
i started roofing but when i got
separated i lost my job with the roof in
the company because they were my family
so i started selling neon and one day i
got approached by one of the guys and he
goes listen
like in june of 91 92
92 the guy comes up to me and he goes
listen
um they're hiring in my office
and i put your name in the hat because
they're looking for these
coast guys and you know you have an
accent and blah blah blah and
that's what works so i didn't know what
he was talking about you know i thought
it was
i just didn't have no idea he goes
are you is this something you're
interested in he goes how can i
how can i be interested in something i
don't know what job you're putting me in
for he goes
i'll set up a meeting with you and you
go meet with the guy and then if you
want to train
and work for them i thought it was
stocks i i thought it was bonds i
thought it was
something to do with something like that
like cold calling people
i couldn't get a stock license because i
had the felony so i
i didn't know what i was going to do but
when i ended up meeting with the guy
he did something that i had never even
knew existed
and he worked for he owned the sports
betting service
and what they do is you pay them a
certain amount of money
and they tell you who to gamble on and i
was like what the [__]
i thought i was 29 years old and i had
i never knew i never heard anything like
it you know i
grew up in numbers in my house my mother
had a numbers operation
and she bet baseball but i never knew
there were people who gave
out information and you paid them when
they came to me and they offered me the
job
you know they offered me uh it was like
a flat
they said well you know what kind of
bills do you have and i told them that i
was in [__] heavy debt
uh and they said well we'll pay you a
flat
versus commission for the first month
we'll give you
500 a week you know and after that
you're on [__] commission
i was a little scared you know we're all
hesitant but
when you got a 100 commission job
the good thing about it is there's no
ceiling to your [__] income
you control your own [__] income it
takes balls to get involved in something
like that
i had done it when i sold cars you know
when you sell cars they only give you
the [__] 800 or a month you know 1200
a month
for the first 90 days after that you're
on commission basis
and you have to learn to live like that
for some people they can't handle that
[__]
i [__] said listen i got nothing to
lose
right i'm broke as it is already i'm
broke as a [__] joke
what do i have to lose so i had sold
stuff before
i thought i was a salesman before like i
knew how to sell like at a car wash
i knew how to put bids together for
roofing but i had never sold
sporting information so i
let myself go and i went in there and
let them train me
and it was [__] interesting work
you worked six days a week from
uh the only day off was wednesday
and your weekends are [__] like they
tell you that when you get the job like
if you go play if your wife plans
something or your girlfriend plans
something
you're [__] but you have a chance of
making
a ton of [__] money i went to work
for these guys not knowing what
to expect and sure enough you know i
started in august
and by mid-september the the the
guarantee ended
and i started making some money i
started making 600 a week
then in october i started making like
800 a week
then in november i was up to like a
thousand a week which was
a [__] shitload of [__] money
for me at the time and december
everything is on you got college
basketball you got
nba basketball you got pro football you
got college football the bowl games you
got the nhl
i mean it's high [__] level and i
think that december i ended up making
like maybe uh
i don't know 8 000 for the month that
was [__]
something i had never even dreamed of
january was the super bowl
and it slows down a little bit for the
playoffs and stuff
and then what they do is if you had a
good year
they let you stay till march madness
and if you had a really good year up to
march madness
they let you work baseball season
baseball season
you don't make a lot of money it's only
like maybe five or six or seven guys in
the office
during football season it was 17 to 18
guys in a [__] office
yelling screaming you know you got to
call people how you doing mike
this is uh pete [__] smith from
[__] all-star sports how you doing
today and
people like i don't need your [__]
help go [__] yourself and you got to
call them back and
and it was great work because i laughed
my i mean i loved my job
as soon as i started making money i love
bugging people i love calling people up
and
you know you call them at work and you
think you know anybody will talk to you
at work
when they're at work people will talk to
you because they're killing time they
don't give a [__] they'll talk to you
about anything
they'll take the call they'll let you
pitch them at home it's a different
[__] story so i would like to call
people at work so i would
call them at the office and [__] i never
gambled when i was there
because it taught me that
no matter what you do people are going
to [__] lose
like the odds are always against you
so i i wasn't gambling when i was there
but i was selling information
but it was really weird i gambled as a
child i gambled
not as a child i gambled i started
gambling when i was about
17 because my friends did it and by the
time i was 19 i learned my [__]
lesson it wasn't for me i couldn't
[__] win
every once in a while i won but i always
caught a [__] beating
i got memorable [__] beatings i
remember one time
that's why i play if i gamble now i look
a lot at the lines because the lines
confuse the [__] out of you like one
year the sixes were hot
and [__] they played the nets and the
nets were giving the sixes four points
well we all took the [__] sixes and
the nets beat them up right because it
was a suckers bet i didn't see that
before the [__] uh the the game
started but
you know those are all memorable [__]
beatings i remember one time
i owed a bookie money and he came to
beat me up with a [__] chain
and two days later the guy killed
himself can you [__] believe that
like on a tuesday i'm playing basketball
behind hash ways
this dude shows up with a [__] chain
link and he goes i want my [__] 300
i'm gonna bust you in the head with it
and all of a sudden i started
putting the money together and a friend
of mine said don't even bother
the guy killed himself i mean that was
[__] horrible and then in 83
before i left to colorado we were really
involved in gambling we were
you know i ended up robbing a [__]
jewelry store in 82
because i bet pittsburgh against dallas
on a monday night football game and i
lost
and there was a teacher i owed the money
to and i couldn't let him down so
i had to pay him i mean when you gamble
you gotta [__] pay
all those lessons but the lesson that
killed me the most
about gambling was my roommate at the
time his name was ferny i loved him to
death
he had never put a bet in his life
before never
ever ever that he put a bed in and
uh one day he came up to me and he goes
hey man what are you guys talking about
when you and stinky talk
about sports what are you guys talking
about we're talking about gambling he
goes i want to give it a shot
the first bet he put in he ended up
winning like
1200 bucks and he went on a [__] tear
for three months and he ended up losing
at the super bowl
he ended up losing 80 000 and he had to
pay that back
he had to get three [__] jobs
three [__] jobs and he paid it back
in the summer
when i saw him go through that i decided
[__] it if it's if i'm gonna give my
money away i might as well give it to
the coke dealer
and look out a window because at least
when you do coke you look out a window
you [__] crawl you look for little
pieces on the floor you know what i'm
saying
when you gamble you just give your money
to some [__] guy on thursday at a
[__] diner
and i didn't like that at all so i
stopped [__] gambling that was the
end of
my gambling career and for years i never
gambled
but after i worked at the sports betting
service
i learned so much about degenerate
gamblers that it [__] petrified me
but
i also learned how to bet
smart that's what i learned
after that [__] job
so if you listen to my story
i was a good salesman my first year
i don't know what i made that year
if i made 25
30 000 not even in five months i was
lucky i don't think i made that but they
told me
on january 20th that i was only gonna
work to the end of the [__] super
bowl
and i was so [__] depressed about it
because i had tried my heart out to be
good at this
that i was heartbroken i mean i went
into a [__] depression
and that's why i came back here in 1993
in january of 93 because
i was so depressed that i had lost i
didn't lose my job
they just weren't going to take me back
till august and it broke my [__]
heart
so that's how much i love the [__]
job
i came back here i started comedy pretty
much
with that job i still remember being in
the broker joker contest in 91
and the guys from that office coming to
see me and cheering me on and me winning
we had a great [__] time in that
office we
every monday night for monday night
football we'd finish at seven
and they take us out to dinner at a
[__] at a different restaurant in
boulder and we'd watch
the game uh once every three months
he would take us to vegas for three days
we'd stay at the mirage we'd go to steve
wynn's office
and look out his balcony onto the
[__] the mirage thing blowing up
it was just a great [__] experience
for a kid like me
i went back in 93 uh i went to
i was kind of upset with them so a guy
had left
that was one of their best salesmen and
i went and worked with him for a few
weeks
but then when the main guy called me
back and he goes what are you doing
you know i was gonna bring you back i
went back to work for them and i'm happy
i did
i ended up working for them for three
football seasons my last season
was 94 going into the 95 year
and that december i made 60 000
[__] dollars i must have paid 50
000 to the attorneys i must have snorted
000 i caught up on my child support
and if you guys know my story in june
25th we just had the anniversary of 1995
i left boulder to pursue my comedy
[__] career
i never gambled again you know i didn't
put a bet until
mcgregor fought nate diaz that was my
first
bet the first time and i got it right
you know i looked at the line
i went to the [__] uh
to the uh to the way in and i saw that
he flinched
and i remember that i put like 400 on
them and i didn't have that much money
in my account i had to call my wife
in the middle of the night it was like
11 30. i called it i woke her up and i
go you got to put more money in my
account
and she goes what are you doing at 11 30
with all this money i go i'm not doing
blow
i'm just putting in a [__] bet on
[__] nate diaz and she goes you
better [__] win because we need this
money and
nate diaz ended up winning and you know
i started betting little ufc fights i
always would go to the ufc fights
and bet a little bit at the fight she we
would always take like 20s and singles
and me and ari would bet other people
like five bucks for this fight but
there was no line involved or anything
like that now
draftkings came along and became my
sponsor and
just like my sponsors today you know
performance and uh
relief band and all this stuff i try
everything
i you know for me to try to push
something on you
i have to try it first so when i got
draftkings
you know i went on the site you know i
don't know how to play cards
you know i'm half [__] [__] uh i
don't know how to really play dice i
never had the patience to [__] sit
there
but i know how to play sports you know
and i i didn't get involved with
uh basketball as much or baseball it was
just
football little bets and then uh this
year you know i
i don't know if you guys remember danny
b from the church of what's happening
now
great friend of mine great [__]
sports bettor
you know he moved up north but now he
moved back to pennsylvania
and he's been laying low i'm going to
have him on a couple of weeks because i
miss him
uh and i started talking to
the philly godfather you know i was i
was looking at his picks on twitter you
know every night i would look at his
little
free picks on twitter and i've got to
tell you something he wasn't doing
[__] bad you know so
every once in a while if i'm bored i'll
see what he's giving out that night
and i'll throw 25 50 bucks on it whether
it's baseball if
if i see there's a game on at night or
something i'll call him up or
whatever and you know what uh right now
i'll show you my [__] draftkings i
think i'm up
i think i put 500 in there to start and
i
still think i'm at like 540. i mean i
don't
i'm not a degenerate or whatever but i'm
having a great time
uh i think saturday
but he gave me a baseball game this days
listen guys this times i bet
25 bucks and i win like 10 bucks on a
baseball game
and i don't give a [__] it's just a
little fun for me you know it's just
something to do this you know it was
rough for a lot of months and i hate
just sitting there watching tv i'm not
telling you to [__] gamble i don't
you know what if it's up to me i'd
rather you not gamble but
if you're gonna gamble i want you to do
it the right way i want you to win money
that's why you gamble to win money
a little bit of money to have fun you're
not gonna gamble like i did when i was a
kid to [__] do blow like i used to
gamble like you know
oh i need twenty thousand i'm gonna bet
twenty thousand you're not gonna [__]
win
you're a loser what i'm trying to do
with this podcast is
if you're gonna gamble there's a way to
[__] do it
be smart about it have somebody who's
guiding you
don't stick to that rule you know stick
to that rule if you do sign
with a handicapper like the guy i'm
going to introduce to you today
if he tells you to bet something bet it
the way he tells you
when i was a when i worked for the
sports of handicapped i was blessed
and i hate saying that word i was really
fortunate to work for the guys i did
because they were honest you know most
sports companies that you sign with
they take like say tonight you got
milwaukee or tonight you got phoenix
against the clippers i think tonight's
game seven i don't [__] know
right they give if they have 300 people
they'll give 150 people
uh the clippers and then they'll give
the other half of the people the phoenix
sons
the company i work for didn't do that
they were [__] straight up
[__] gangsters they did their
homework i could tell you [__]
stories about people they had on the
inside
girlfriends of college players
girlfriends and side pieces of
mistresses of
basketball players and football players
i'm not here to throw anybody under the
bus
but they that's how they if they made
a million dollars a year they paid out a
half a million
to get little information you know just
little things
that could change the [__] game it's
like an episode of sopranos
paulie walnuts is talking about one
night he's out in a bar and he sees joe
namath come in
[__] drunk as [__] and he called
everybody he knew and told him to bet
against name it the next day
because he was drunk as [__] as midnight
and his game was at one o'clock
that type of information makes you money
i don't want you to just bet like a
[__]
yahoo i'm doing this podcast today out
of respect for draftkings and i respect
for you guys that have been
you know hitting me up and going joey
you know we went on draftkings we really
enjoy it
but i lost listen vegas
i don't know how to say this vegas
doesn't get bigger and bigger
because mike klein and me are winning
money there's no way
the odds are you lose listen pete rose
lost
michael jordan lost and he played the
game you know there was 10 guys before
them who played the game and gambled
they're too heady you have to know the
lines
you know i think the best that i ever do
is when i bet the ufc
a couple weeks ago i had moreno and it
was a big upset i think i bet 25 but i
won
[__] 75 bucks i had i i bet against
nate diaz
and i bet i think 50 bucks
to win 10 or to win 20. that was the
dumbest bet i haven't made in my life
but i just wanted to see if i still knew
how to read the lines
and i still know how to read the lines
you got to look at the lines and go wow
this is weird especially you know with
the with the ufc
they give you the over on the rounds you
know they'll give you over four rounds
and stuff like that so
right now at this time i consider myself
really good
at the ufc and that's it i can't pick a
basketball game
to save my life baseball i don't know i
don't even know what the standings are
i have no [__] idea but if you're
gonna gamble
do me a favor do it responsibly and do
it with help and don't be a [__]
yahoo
the guy i'm gonna introduce to you now
is a great guy
he's legit i love what he does and i
gotta be honest
he's won me a little bit of cash check
it out it's a very small interview i did
i just wanted to introduce you to him
and i just wanted to talk about this
today because
a lot of people been hit me up ever
since i got on draftkings
and i wanted to do an episode
specifically about this
here's the philly godfather enjoy
philly what's happening my friend what's
up guys
how are you my buddy what's going on why
you so quiet today and [__] you're not
on twitter [__] telling people
vip members win 18 000 this weekend
i want to ask you some questions you
know uh you've given me some pics the
last couple weeks you're [__] solid
as [__]
i enjoy it how did you become the philly
godfather
i want to know this is always that
the good and the bad who gives a [__]
that's what we're here for
man yeah you know i grew up in philly
and uh you know
poor greek family my father had hot dog
carts and
he stuck me in a hotdog cart at the age
of eight and it was actually the best
education i ever could have got uh you
know i never went to school dropped out
of high school in ninth grade started
working the streets
and you really learned the value of a
dollar in a hotdog cart you learn how to
network with people you meet so many
people from so many different
you know parts of life you know we had
hot dog carts in center city we met
doctors and stock brokers and lawyers
and it's just
it was one of the greatest educations i
ever you know i've ever had
and uh you know and slowly start meeting
people next thing you know uh an old
childhood friend approached me
and uh he was moving money for some big
guys in vegas this is back in 1988 this
is before
you know no one had a computer no one
had a dom best screen no one knew with
the lines where everyone was working off
on newspaper lines
and he approached me and he knew i knew
a lot of people and
i was a street kid and he said if you
can find me some bookies we can make
some money
and that's how it all started man a long
time ago joe
what do you mean if he found you some
bookies like he had
information he had it he was getting a
lot of information from vegas
he was moving money for some of the
sharpest uh sports bettors in the world
back then
uh there's no reason to mention their
names but right he wants he wanted me to
find outs for him he wanted me to find
guys we can bet with and he was going to
give me a 20 with a work off
what that meant was you know if i could
find him 10 bookies and we went 10 000 a
week my pay was 2 000 out of that 10
grand
and the rest we had to turn in and then
they would turn it out to vegas so
i was that i was a mover i was moving
money for you know some of the sharpest
guys uh
you know out in vegas back then as a kid
i was 18 19 years old
and that's how i got started as a mover
and uh you know
at first i thought he was bullshitting
me because back then i didn't know you
know i
you know you hear danvers degenerate
gamblers and you think they're all
losers
you know but these guys had the hot
games they had you know the best
information
sharpest information in the world and
slowly he didn't have to tell me no more
i mean every week we were winning money
and every week
you know my bankrolls kept stacking so
that's basically how it all started i
was a mover i was moving
money for some of the sharpest guys in
the world and later on i realized like
you know what if i lose these apps what
if i can't get them these connections i
want to learn how to handicap the games
so i kind of reverse engineered uh the
games that we were moving on i was
trying to figure out you know why are
they
these baseball games was it the weather
was it the humidity uh was it the
pitching was it the
umpires was it the stadiums what made
the ball you know go out
you know somebody watched baseball they
hit five six home runs and other nights
they can't hit the ball at all so what
made that ball pop in baseball
and a lot of it had to do with weather
so i basically reverse engine
engineered the games whether it was
baseball football basketball college
basketball
and the more you get into it the more
you start learning about regressional
stats
what uh regressing to the means is
uh you know different factors historical
probabilities on these games what
happened in the past
and how it may affect the future so you
start looking for productive indicators
you start looking for
little bits of gold that'll help you
when you're trying to make an education
you know an educated guess on on these
games in the night tonight
now how does the line how does reading
the line
come into this because i took a beating
as a kid
you know i you looked at the lines and
you
you got sucked in you know the biggest
beating i took was i think
like the chargers were playing oakland
on a monday night game and
they were given seven the line went up
to seven and a half so we decided to bet
it and the [__]
we got killed and i had to rob a jewelry
store to [__]
pay the bookie because you know you got
to pay the book i mean he was a friend
of mine you know like i knew him
he was a teacher at the high school so i
knew him and i had to give him the money
and i got turned off by it you know once
i lost i said listen if i'm going to
gamble
i'll gamble on me i'd rather snort coke
and look out a window
than [__] give money to a bookie
every thursday that's what got me away
from gambling
but then in 91 i hooked up with a sports
betting crew
and i looked at it from a different
perspective i wasn't betting the games
i looked at it as they were great
salesmen they knew exactly what they
were doing
but i learned a lot like you said from
gambling from being on the phones
and calling people and when they would
tell like when a lot of people would
tell me the same pick
yeah i would see it lose so if i would
call you and say
philly it's pete you know i'm going with
the
[__] i got a two two game parlay
whatever
you would say what do i need you for i
got the mets tonight oh i got the
[__] yankees tonight you get ten
yankees
you know they're gonna lose yeah you
definitely want to be on the other side
of the public
right the bookie wins a lot more than
they lose but but the squares went as
well
and that's why i tell people all the
time the worst thing you can do is wake
up on a sunday during the nfl season
and remember what happened last week
recency buys will get you killed
when you're looking to place a wager if
you haven't done your research you
haven't done your homework on these
games
and you just wake up on a sunday and
you're like oh they look great last week
i'm betting them again
well that's a recipe for disaster i mean
when you before you buy your first home
you're gonna look around the
neighborhood you're gonna run the comps
you're gonna check out the school
districts
you can look at the upgrades in the
house you're gonna try and find value
in that house before you make that
purchase and i know when i bought my
first home
i probably looked at 40 houses before i
bought a house i probably spent about
200 hours before i
made that purchase now imagine you just
spent four or five hours a day on a
certain game
handicapping that game and researching
that game you're gonna have a better
chance of winning that game
than losing that game but most people
don't put the work in and that's what we
do we spend about 10 12 hours a day
researching
you know as much information as possible
but at the end of the day it's an
educated guess
and this is a market like any other
market man you're gonna have your wins
you're gonna have your losses
but if you do your homework and you
really look at the games for what they
are
and you can find some clarity in the
market and you like the price you're
gonna make some money
you know i i got hooked up with
draftkings and
i like you know i like any other
sponsor i have i i go into the products
you know i want to see
if the products are any good before i
pass it on you know what i'm saying and
what i started doing last uh maybe when
i moved here
a friend of mine invited me over every
sunday
to watch football with his childhood
friends jimmy florentine
great bunch of guys you know and i would
just throw in side bets there you know
and it was just for fun
20 bucks 30 bucks whatever and then i
finally opened up the draftkings account
and i started having fun but it wasn't
like when i was a kid
i wasn't you know when i was betting as
a kid i was betting the snort coke
and to get laid like i was trying to
figure it out how much do i need this
week
i need two eight balls i need to take
her out to dinner i need to make rent
okay so i need 1800.
let me call the book and put a bet in
for two thousand and i lose ten out of
ten times now i gotta hide for a week
i gotta rob i gotta borrow so it just
i didn't [__] now i bet twenty five
fifty bucks you know i can't sit and
watch a whole [__] game
but i'll watch a quarter you know i
watch this
i watch a couple innings you know just
you're sitting here anyway you're gonna
sit here a [__] night
every night there's an nba game on every
night this
couple i have you know ten thousand
[__] channels i don't have
any of the sports packages or anything
but i just find it
like i'm having a good time it's not an
everyday thing
you know uh i made some really good
money on the fights last time
you know i picked some of the underdogs
i'm looking forward to the fights
this time around i'm looking at that the
nba finals
you know this whole [__] thing you
can't call it anymore you know kwami's
out
how do you work with all these like
kwame leonard's out the other guy had
coveted
like i just avoid the game i mean
there's so many moving parts but
right regressional stats i mean we'll
take uh
the clippers for for example i mean paul
george puts up 40 reggie jacks
put up 20. uh morris put up 20. it kind
of outperformed their norm you know
they almost doubled their output in
scoring and that's going to be hard to
continue against the phoenix sun's team
that plays some great defense so i know
they played lights out last game
and they won the game over phoenix at
seven point underdogs but to continue to
play at that elevated you know
level uh to come in night and night out
and and give it an optimum performance
it's going to be very difficult for you
know
for the clippers to beat the suns uh you
know i know the sun's up 3-2 we got
futures on the suns at 49.1 that we gave
out the beginning of the season
so we're kind of happy with the position
we have but in all honesty i can't see
the clippers winning this series it's
going to be very difficult
paul george's gonna have to play lights
out and that whole team's gonna have to
you know play above what they're used to
playing
in order to beat the suns i don't see
that happening uh
with the hawks now you know trey's
banged up
that's gonna be it's gonna be tough for
the hawks to beat this milwaukee's team
uh you know we already saw the total go
from 222 to 218 on this matchup tonight
and that's basically because no one
knows if trey young's gonna be 100
or not i mean he's been playing lights
out he's been carrying that team he's
like the new allen iverson he's
unbelievable he's so hard
you know to match up with but if he's
not 100
that team don't have no chance so you
know injuries are big
uh guys are banged up right now it's
late in the season
i think it's gonna be milwaukee against
phoenix in the finals and it's gonna be
a great series
how many people work to make the philly
godfather
do its thing how many people you have
there's a bunch of guys uh
we got six guys in the office i got
another five guys running numbers crunch
numbers uh so there's 11 or 12 guys
some guys leave some guys come back you
know you know but
it's just it's a big operation it's it's
not easy to do a one-man operation
i'm leap at every sport seven days a
week 365 days a year and if you don't
have
seven eight nine ten guys helping you
it's not gonna happen well it's like
having the yankees
you know when when the yankees make
their team
the yankees say well we're gonna have to
have
for us to win the world series four guys
have to be batting 300 okay
four guys not all nine guys
but four guys gotta be hot you know like
so you don't know who's gonna be hot at
some time of the year
when the yankees would build their
[__] championship teams
you know the guy you expected to be
[__] hot during the
playoffs goes cold and some other guy
comes to [__] life
you know what i'm saying that you you
never really expected i i think back to
the
to i think the 75 world series when the
cincinnati reds played the boston red
sox
i don't know what year it was 70 you
know tony perez did great the whole
season
come the world series against the red
sox he's owen 17
going into game six and he bangs a
single in game
six and they [__] win it so he went
one for 17
but the one mattered it's the same with
your team
yeah absolutely the long long year
right on randomness even though it's an
educated guess when we've done our
homework
you know it it's the law of big numbers
man of infinite numbers you we can go
17 and 2 then we can go 2 and 15. it's
just
you know we're betting on randomness you
never know what happens you can bet on
the kansas city chiefs
and they're killing everybody then
mahomes breaks his leg in a football
game and there goes your bet
so anything and everything can happen
we've seen it over the years
so yeah there's a lot of variants
involved but as long as you keep
plugging away as long as you keep doing
your homework and your research
you know in football to beat that vig to
beat that minus 110 you got to win 52.4
percent of your wages or more
and that's what we do we've done it for
the past 30 years and we continue to do
it but there's a lot of hard work
involved
and you're going to have your runs your
good runs you're going to have your hot
streaks your call streaks
but at the end of the year we always end
up with the money because we do our
homework
it's just like any other market man if
if you do your homework you're going to
make money
if you just start picking games and
betting games because you like what you
saw last year in trouble
no i don't like losing money you know me
i don't like losing money especially
[__] gambling so
for me to bet something like you help me
from time to time
with fights i'm good because i learned
from rogan
a lot about fighting but rogan is so
knowledgeable about the fight game i
look at the line
for fights where he doesn't look at that
you know
i mean people tell you i have people say
to me well how how can you win
when michael jordan [__] played
basketball and couldn't win pete rose
played baseball and was losing games you
know they get too involved in it that's
why i think that
i like putting in like maybe like if i
was a full-time gambler
i would bet anywhere from five to six
games a week
but that's my biggest odds of winning is
keeping my
action low you know and hitting them
heavy for every [__] thing i got
that's the way i learned to gamble
if you're gonna bang a [__] out
bang them out for everything
once you start doing the parlays and the
teasers and all that [__]
that's when you get in trouble that's
what i feel i'm not a genius
but that's how i feel from my years of
doing this [__]
yeah i mean if you've got a 14 parlay
right
and you win two and you lose two you
lose the parlay but if you wrap the game
straight up
you break even you pay a little vague on
the side uh so that's basically partly
difficult to hit you know they're more
for fun uh but like i said
draftkings had a great promotion for me
they gave me 50
of my sign up bonus i actually went down
ac and i fired away on the houston
astros now the answers we had taken
at 16-1 which was a great bet their odds
right now are down to six and a half to
one
now the other day i was down there and
they were still around eight to one
but they gave me such a huge sign up
bonus i threw another thousand on the
astros at eight to one
and they gave me about 4 500 and free
money so i put the whole 4 500
on the astros as well so now i increase
my odds from 8 to 1 to 44 to 1
with those free bets that's why i love
draftkings so much because of
you know the stuff they give out and the
reason why i like the astros so much is
they had one of the toughest schedules
in the first half of baseball season and
they got the best run differential in
baseball right now
and in the second half of the baseball
season they got one of the easiest
schedules
while the oakland a's who are a great
team and they're right behind them they
got one of the toughest schedules
in the second half of baseball season so
i see the ashes winning that division
and the other reason why i like him is
come the trade deadline they're going to
go out and they're going to get somebody
they need where
teams like tampa bay teams like oakland
teams like san fran that more
analytically driven
they really don't do that they stick
with the guns that they have and i i
don't see them spending money like the
astro spend money
tampa bay had one of the cheapest
payrolls oakland always has one of the
cheapest payrolls where houston will go
out
and get that big stud picture so i think
houston can make
a deep run i think they got a great shot
at one of the playoffs they got a chip
on their shoulder
everyone from new york hates them
everyone calls them cheaters so i think
they got that driving force behind
plus the fact that they got one of the
easiest second half schedules in
baseball and i'm sitting at 44 to 1.
i mean i got big money on just with
draftkins i got 5500 with draftkings i
got another four dimes
uh on the street at 16-1 so i think
they're the team that you can make some
money on
that's [__] amazing that's amazing
that you've narrowed it down
that much to a [__] science i like i
said i i wanted to have you one
to explain to people you know what you
do
uh the the percentages
you know people call you up and say i'd
go 80 percent nobody goes [__] 80
if you go 80 you wouldn't be [__]
telling me you'd be in [__] vegas
you know driving around like i knew a
guy who used to play blackjack
and he's from philly probably a friend
of yours
and i saw him go into i mean i saw him
you know i used to
i used to open for dice on the road and
he would
meet us at the dice show and then me him
jim norton bobby lee would all go gamble
with him
and you know he'd go into let's say the
mirage
he would go into a private [__] room
a guy would bring his chips
you know and he would play for 20
minutes 30 minutes and he had a system
and he'd make
65 000. i mean he bought dice a [__]
escalade i mean it was crazy
he gave me three
he got thrown out of a couple casinos
he's still out in vegas
he's still making money i don't know how
the [__] he does it
but you know he showed us he goes you
know i just go in there for 20 anything
over
30 or 40 minutes my odds of losing
increase he goes i know what i'm gonna
do by the first
20 or 25 minutes i won't sit there past
you know he had
different pointers because it's all a
game of numbers it's percentages
so yeah absolutely i mean the same
amount of low cards as high cards
seven eights and nines are neutrals we
used to count cards uh but they
they've made it so difficult for you to
win even accountant cards
because they change the bet spreads the
way you can fire away
once they realize that you're counting
all the pitfalls come down and they
basically throw you out or they tell you
they'll shelf after every deal so
you got to really camouflage what you're
doing at the black deck table we did it
back
in the 90s we got thrown out of ac so
many times
but it's a lot of work i mean there's
there's times you and your edge is so
small
and they've made it even smaller over
the years but it is a lot of work
sometimes we'd sit at that table
for four or five hours and the count
wouldn't come and we end up losing money
so it's just like any other business man
you got to work hard
you got to stay focused and if you got a
small edge you got to take advantage of
that edge and you got to fire
because that's how you make money in
this business you know uh
what do you guys usually do a week like
on
a right now you have baseball and
basketball this isn't
really the busiest time of the year i
know
once october comes that's your [__]
hate day you got
football you got nba basketball you got
[__] hockey you got bowl season in
december i mean it's a [__] you know
now it's like
a lot of people don't understand
baseball gambling so they don't do it
guys like me i don't my mother bet
baseball i don't know how to bet
baseball you know i don't even know what
the [__] yankees are doing
you know you told me about houston i
thought they were cheaters yeah i don't
[__] know what's going on
but uh like what kind of numbers are you
doing a week now
during this like i call this the slow
time
a lot of yeah people are good yeah we
call it the dead zone even the nba
playoffs they're winding down
uh baseball right now it depends i mean
it depends what our edges if we find a
strong edge we might increase our bet
size to maybe like a four times bet
or a three times bet and we'll fire away
but average plays a day
for me uh you might get anywhere from
one to like five plays a day tops even
with the nba
rocking right now football season is a
lot more you got football you got
college football and then college
basketball kicks in and you know how
many games are during college basketball
however 1b8 comes back so there's a lot
more
volume there uh but yeah we firing the
nfl i mean you see my futures tickets
the last
four years 2017 before the season
started i gave out the eagles to win the
super bowl
2018 i had the bears but i had them at
95 to 1.
and if you remember in those playoffs
the eagles barely beat the bears
the saints barely beat the eagles and
the rams barely beat the saints so i
thought that was wide open that
that year that's why i took such a long
shot with the bears which was a great
bet
uh the following year uh we we came back
uh
and then last year i had san fran the
year before that had san fran
at 28-1 i had him to win the west i had
him win the nfc
and last year if you remember back in
march on twitter i gave out the tampa
bay buccaneers at 50-1
to win the super bowl and the buffalo
bills at 30 to one now
the bills almost got there but you know
the buccaneers got us the money
so we've had some good good seasons with
the nfl over the last four years
what's your strongest football is
probably your
best or is it basketball or is it
baseball
what does the philly godfather think his
specialty is
man it's got to be the nfl nfl then
college football then college basketball
college basketball is very random
and i tell people all the time college
basketball very difficult because the
lines move
so fast and you might see a three four
five point move on total sometimes even
higher than that
so if i bet a game i'll move the line
and by the time you get it it might have
moved a point or two
and you lose a lot of the value a lot of
the value has been extracted out of that
number
where in the nfl you know it's a big
market it's it's it's the king kong of
uh
sports betting there's so much money
being brought into the market where it's
harder to move the lines
and uh i think you got a better shot at
winning in the nfl in college football
uh college basketball is a little more
difficult if somebody
is looking to play some bets
or need some help how do they contact
you just go to my website we never
solicit no business i don't have an 800
number i don't call people
i don't send spam emails uh we basically
have a zero acquisition fee we don't
spend no money on advertising we let our
resume
speak for ourselves and everything's
documented i've given it all out on
twitter
giving a lot of social media all the
radio shows and tv shows i do you just
go to phillygodfather.com
you stop by my twitter account at philly
godfather and that's basically it
you're a [__] jeep brother and i'm
happy you took the time today
to zoom in with me because i think the
world of you you know you've given me
some winners
and i really wanted to expose you to the
world i think you're a good guy
and you have great intentions i know
that they're writing a movie about you i
mean you're the real deal you
you know danny and you know tim and you
know all the whole [__] crew and
and i love you you know i love that you
keep in touch and i really wanted to
let people know you're available to them
like
if they want to bet with draftkings or
whatever they want to do
if they got a bookie whatever you know
it's great to [__] collect
it's great to win you know and uh
i just wanted to help people and turn
them on to you and what you do
brother i appreciate it i'll give you
guys some nfl futures we bet that's cool
you i bet the patriots
uh to go over nine wins i better plus
150 to make the playoffs
i bet the chargers over nine wins i got
a huge bet
on the browns over 10 and a half wins uh
regular season win totals i got the
browns winning the super bowl at 20-1
this team is stacked
i know this team has sucked for maybe 20
years for
excluding last year they had one of the
worst records in the nfl
but good things come to you know the
people that wait and this year this
cleveland browns team is stacked they
got a great shot to get there
in the nfc side i think there's a lot of
value on washington i took my 70 to one
as a long shot
49ers are going to be a lot better this
year they were one of the most injured
teams in the nfl last year
but the browns the chargers watch out
for those teams watch out for the 49ers
and watch out for uh the washington
football team that's [__] crazy it's
june and you're already talking football
you're already betting football so
your jimmy is prepared i love you philly
keep me posted if anything comes in
you know where to find me all right i
love you to death and the web page again
is
the phillygodfather.com there you go you
bad [__] i hope you enjoy
philly i'll be in touch all right
brother
thank you very much for coming on uncle
joey's joining on a [__] wednesday
afternoon
thank you stay black thank you
all right we're back i hope you enjoyed
that today guys
i just wanted to do a little thing on
gambling today
just because i got a couple guys on
patreon hit me up a couple guys on
twitter have hit me up you know they've
joined draftkings because of me
thank you and uh they wanted to just
learn
what the [__] was going on like i said
i'm not here
to make you gamble i don't want you to
lose your house i don't want you to
you know i was just talking to my
brother about a friend a dear friend of
ours who
is having a lot of problems with it he
doesn't stop you know he has
hidden sights and all this [__] i don't
want you to go there
when you place a bet if you go on
draftkings i want you to bet with your
[__] head you know
25 30 bucks 50 bucks you're not taking
food out of your family's [__] mouth
i'm not here
to promote gambling in that sense i'm
here to promote gambling in a fun way
you know during the football season
you're cleveland
you're a cleveland browns fan you bet
cleveland browns like the man said you
know
he gave you some great picks on here for
the year for football
and if you enjoy them and if you like
betting baseball or basketball whatever
you [__] like
you always have the [__] option to
hit the philly godfather
and at least win a little bit like i
said
people get hot and people get cold like
we discussed the yankees
they count on four guys being hot in
october
that's why they pay for seven guys they
know three guys
are not gonna [__] and that's the
same thing with us as gamblers
the more you bet the more you lose if
you bet every [__] day
the odds are higher if you bet on what
you truly like
and what you truly believe in and what
you truly know about
and you keep it to three bet i'd rather
make three bets a week at a hundred
and go two out of three and you know
make 150 bucks a week that's 600 a
[__] month you make off gambling if i
had to
it's not what i want to do when i gamble
like i said it's for [__] shits and
giggles i'm not in business to i'm not
laying five dimes that's not never been
me that's i work too hard for my [__]
money
and i got mouse to feed and i got a
[__] daughter these guys that
go on the limb no no no i promote it for
you to have a good time
it's an option and that's it
it was the wednesday joint i hope you
enjoyed the [__] trailer
for the many saints in newark i put it
up on twitter
i put it up on patreon and made my
[__] heartbeat
when my friend sent it to me i almost
[__] passed out um like i said on my
patreon podcast
i'm very very proud of the work i did in
this movie
i think i did my homework on this movie
i i got to learn
about how david chase you know how he
you know i mean david chase
made an intervention funny that is
[__] hilarious
if you ever see it as the sopranos when
they had the intervention
you laugh your [__] ass off you know
i just worked with benny on that tv show
i told you about from the sopranos and i
told him i go you know
i fell in love with david chase before i
even knew him when he made an
intervention funny
so i'm very proud of this movie it comes
out october 1st
uh that's all i got to promote i got no
[__] dates
i got nothing all i got is my heart some
laughs
and this [__] movie right now so the
joint was short today
it was sweet and to the [__] point
we'll be back
monday after the fourth of july to rock
your [__] world it's gonna be a slow
[__] weekend
people ain't gonna be on the [__]
computers anyway but uh
if you are on the [__] computer i'll
be around i'll be
i won't be around saturday and sunday
but i'll be around
up to friday [__] around so if you
need me hit me up i love you guys have a
great week
thank you for watching the joint and now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
jack
all right i want to thank you guys i
want to thank the philly godfather
i want to thank mike everybody for the
support to the joint
but i also want to thank our sponsors to
join us brought to you by
relief ban listen a third of americans
suffer from [__] nausea all right
when i got the surgery i was nauseous
all the [__] time from the pain pills
that's why i'm excited about relief ban
relief band
is number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband
that has been clinically proven to
relieve and prevent nausea and vomiting
check it out [__] right there nice
the product is 100 drug free
and it doesn't make you drowsy and has
zero side effects
this is the kind that you used to you
could only get this in a hospital
but now it's available to everybody and
uncle joey's giving it to you
[__] here's how it works
relief band stimulates a nerve in the
wrist that travels to the part of the
brain that controls nausea
then it blocks the signal sending to
your stomach telling you that you're
sick
relief ban is the only over-the-counter
wearable band that has been used in
hospitals
and oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting
listen like i said in the beginning when
the [__] pain pills get to you
you know any type of pill i take i get
[__]
nauseous stomach ever since i've had my
[__] relief banned
nausea is gone and sure nausea never
is the reason to miss out on life's
important moments right now relief band
has an exclusive offer you ready for
this
go to reliefband.com and use promo code
joey
and you'll receive 20 off plus free
shipping
and no questions asked on a 30-day
money-back guarantee
it's relief ban r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
com use promo code joey for 20
off and get some relief and never get
nausea again
i know you guys got parents grandparents
uncles maybe they have nausea
this makes a nice little [__] gift
for them whatever give it a shot
the joint is also brought to you by
magnesium
breakthrough listen i never even knew
what magnesium was
but if you're an older man like me or if
you're a man you got to go to the doctor
even if you don't want to
if you're ignoring how you feel you need
to listen to this all right
fatigue anxiety and headaches all might
come
back to one thing you're not getting
enough magnesium
i didn't know anything about this
magnesium
breakthrough is the cure magnesium is an
amazing mineral not only does it help
you sleep
it also helps you reduce stress maintain
regular heartbeat
and boost immunity i take one pill in
the morning one in the afternoon
and three before i go to bed at night
right here boom they also have
tremendous
digestion energy it's these are veggie
caps
ketogenesis you also have probiotics i
mean
listen magnesium breakthrough is not
just about magnesium
do me a favor it all starts by you going
to magbreakthrough.com
and slash joey and use code joey to get
10 off joey 10 to save ten percent
eighty percent of the population is
magnesium magnesium deficient
if you don't get the right amounts
you'll eventually end up going to the
doctor for some reason
i'm amazed how much better i sleep and
how rested i feel
in the morning you guys see me i'm
looking good that's because i've been
taking this
this program for the last two months
plus i feel more relaxed and at peace
throughout the day
magnesium breakthrough is the only
organic supplement
that includes seven unique forms of
magnesium
it works fast i feel it about 30 minutes
just pop three capsules before you go to
nappy noodle time
and that's it but what we're gonna do is
it's all starts by you
going through magbreakthrough.commag
breakthrough.com read
learn and if you like it press joey
tender and check out
to save 10 that's magnesium
magnesiumbreakthrough.com
joey and use joey 10 for 10
off listen when you wake up in the
morning you'll [__] thank me
and then you go back to mag breakthrough
and tell them uncle joey sent you
i want to thank magnesium breakthrough
and i want to thank
relief band for having our backs this
week but most importantly i want to
thank you guys
for always having my back whether it's
on patreon
here youtube twitter i love you
[__] i hope you enjoyed the
trailer
i hope you're as excited as i am and
i'll see you guys monday the 5th
tip top magoo ready to [__] go i love
you
stay black [__] have a great
[Music]
weekend
so
[Music]
you